so we're here looking at children of
morta and tell me about you tell me
about the game all right so my name is
Jacobson Beck I am the narrative
designer on children morta just to like
promote my studio and our publisher
we're doing I'm working with dead mage
studios to develop it a great team over
there our artists are killing it like I
don't wanna brag was like the the pixel
re over here is something like it's it's
doing it it's it's yeah artists yeah so
being developed by dead mage studios but
we are being published by 11 bit Studios
we started talking to about a year ago
and yeah they've enabled us to take
children children were two started off
as a Kickstarter project and we had so
many loyal people come in and fund the
project and make it a reality but 11 mid
studio has come in and is given that
extra little push to make sure we get
everything we want into the game so
that's the background of like the
production but children amor is a
narrative driven hack-and-slash
roguelike where you take control of a
member of a family a family of guardians
who are guard guard guard guard family
of people who are guarding Mount morta
do they guard what they guard
hey guard occasionally week evenings and
weekends I mornings because you get all
the heavy stuff done in the morning and
then you got your afternoon to just go
just do whatever right so yeah you'll be
taking part in the family and Mount
morta is kind of your home the
surrounding lands and it's being invaded
by the corruption which is this evil
black tar substance that's essentially
turning all the creatures into hostile
enemies as well as enslaving the gods
so humanity and like all the good
creatures left or they're in trouble
because there's no godly presence left
it's just you family is a word that's
come up a lot in talking about the game
would you say that how does that tie
into the main theme is that the main
theme it's it's definitely one of the
themes so like you're a family and it
was important that you felt like this
was a cohesive and real group of people
right so when you return back to the hub
after going through a dungeon right
you'll see the family doing all their
random personal things right you'll see
the youngest son bouncing off the walls
because he's slightly energetic you'll
see the oldest daughter playing her
violin what's really important about the
hub is that you'll even see
thought-bubble
pop above their head right on all these
thought bubbles are dynamically linked
to whatever you might be doing in the
dungeon so if you manage to save people
not save them you know assist someone
everyone's going to dynamically react to
that in their own personality there is a
lot of time spent making sure that each
person has a very distinct sound to
their text making sure like you know the
eight-year-old girl doesn't sound like
some 80 year old philosopher right now
obviously eight-year-olds can
occasionally have some really insightful
wisdom that we just forget about but it
needs to be phrased in such a way that
the words used come out of an
eight-year-old right so like there's a
lot of time spent and like that was
that's going back to like this ambience
and making sure that like the main
narratives really great but it's all
supported by the all these additional
factors so now one of the things that's
really kind of fascinating to me what
what in your opinion is the main
challenge of maintaining like narrative
tension in a roguelike because
roguelikes like they're very repetitive
in the sense that you there they're
predicated on failure yeah and so a
player is going to end up playing the
first level far more than they'll play
any later level for sure so how do you
keep that narrative tension going when
they become so familiar with the
beginning but the end is almost alien
it's a great question so for the main
narrative a lot of that is rewarded at
the end of each chapter so after you
essentially a chapter is one dungeon
right so if you go all the way down the
dungeon beat the boss you beat the
chapter and the next one's unlocked for
you and you're usually awarded main
narrative at that point right because we
got to make sure you get that but
obviously you're gonna spend a couple
hours in that first dungeon probably the
most time it's gonna be in these caves
so we got to make sure that you're
getting some narrative and you feel like
the world is evolving the first way we
did that is make sure that just the
environment itself tells a story
sometimes you might see some some dead
bodies like some some caravans and
wagons that have been broken and that's
it and so your imaginations kind of left
to be like what happened to you right so
that that stuff that you'll see in the
world apart from that are random events
that can happen in the level right so
you might walk in and you see this wolf
puppy that's being attacked she's this
wolf puppies trying to
and it's dying mother and it's being
attacked by the corrupted right so you
can save it and then you'll take it back
home with you right and now when it's at
home it's telling you alright if you go
back into the caves you can get some
medicine for it and then you go do that
you bring it back and then you heal the
puppy right and then you get to build a
house for it and now that that wolf
puppy is a permanent fixture in your
house so essentially I guess your main
question was like how do we make sure
that you feel like there's enough
narrative beats going on and it's just
to make sure we got enough of these
random events set in place that you can
constantly feel like the world is
evolving around you so even if you're on
your like tenth time doing doing the
first dungeon you're still encountering
new elements of the world you should for
sure be seeing new stuff almost every
time the entire dungeon is also
procedurally generated you're never
gonna be running through the same
dungeon twice per se you'll be in the
same area of course but never the same
layout are the same enemies essentially
now as a narrative designer how do you
approach pacing it was really difficult
with this one I got to give a lot of
credit to the rest of the team and the
artists and my co-workers being making
making sure the pacing is great because
as a narrative designer all I want to do
is sit and just like write write write
write write but this is a game where you
just want to get into it right so I
spend a lot of time axing words out of
narration so the main the main narrative
in the game and the main narrative
device is narration so none of the
characters have voice overs they all are
their story is told via narrator as if
it's like an old story in front of a
campfire kind of thing right so what was
the question
pacing so it just was important to make
sure that anytime we gave you a
cinematic it was short to the point and
it got the emotion across and the way we
kind of delivered all that was just
making sure that at key moments like for
instance beating a dungeon you were
given that and it's also important to
note that all those random encounters
they're all of the same quality is the
main narrative like they're all like the
same voice over
quality same cinematic value but it is
all completely random and not necessary
to see our do in order to complete the
game so the goal is to help hopefully
make sure that you're hitting enough of
those beats to make sure that you're
getting you feel like the world's
evolving around you so it's it's a
little bit of luck it's a little bit of
a making sure the random generator in
the game is giving you enough enough of
an option to pursue this additional
narrative how can people follow the
development of children more dead just
as kind of a lead out cool well we got a
website you can of course go check that
out we occasionally do blog posts either
about development or about anything that
might be going on we try to do some lore
up there occasionally as well as like
some background information on like the
actual develop the systems in the game
per se right easily though Twitter find
us at children amorta and you can find
us there you can either follow dead mage
studios or 11-bit studios because
they're going to be pushing updates
there as well so that'll be your best
way to look into it alright thank you so
much for for that looking forward to
track and more of children of morta as
it develops over the next while early
2018 is kind of our estimated launch
date early 2018 I mean it got some
matters on PC Xbox one and ps4